[Music]
right now somewhere in the universe a
giant star is detonating creating a huge
cosmic explosion called a supernova
supernovas are a big giant dramatic end
to a star's life
all stars die but only the biggest go
out with a bang first star to go
supernova we think it has to be at least
eight times more massive than our Sun
it's so easy to think of our Sun as this
incredibly gigantic thing but our Sun is
absolutely tiny compared to some of the
giant stars in the sky
we can see some of these giant stars
with the naked eye and the tenth
brightest in the night sky is a red
supergiant around fifteen times the mass
of the Sun
beatlejuice beatlejuice is so big that
if you're at a place in our own solar
system it would stretch to the orbit of
Jupiter this is one of the biggest
beasts in the galaxy
it's a star also that is on the verge of
death Betelgeuse is less than 10 million
years old but this huge stars days are
numbered it's ready to blow and when it
does we'll see a region of sky brighten
for 14 days until it's nearly as bright
as a full moon it is going to be one of
the most spectacular shows in history
[Music]
and it could happen at any moment I mean
this is the thing I often stand outside
in my yard in the wintertime I look up
at Orion and I see Betelgeuse I'd like
explode
so what will make beetlejuice goes
supernova to understand a giant stars
death we need to understand its life
from the day it's born until the day it
dies a star's life was a constant battle
gravity is pulling in and energy pushing
out the interior of a star is fusing
countless atomic nuclei together
atoms are ramming into each other
getting very very close if they get
close enough they'll actually stick and
form a larger atom every second a giant
star fuses seventh and a half billion
tons of hydrogen that amount of energy
is roughly equivalent to about 100
billion atomic bombs per second that's a
big-ass explosion
this explosive energy threatens to blow
the star apart but the stars own massive
gravity keeps the lid on everything in
the universe is a fight between the
inward force of gravity and the outward
force of pressure or energy every single
star in the sky even our own Sun is an
incredibly dynamic battleground in many
ways stars are an explosion that are
actually too big to explode gravity
holds it together this battle between
these two opposing forces determines the
life and death of the star and this is
where size matters the more massive the
star the more gravity pushes inward and
the harder the star has to push outwards
to keep itself alive
very massive stars are like stars on
steroids they have a lot of fuel to burn
they're so powerful that they use up
their fuel at a rapid rate
massive stars like Betelgeuse are giant
factories fusing lighter elements into
heavier ones but the hard work doesn't
start until their final years for around
90% of their life they fuse hydrogen
into helium but eventually the hydrogen
starts running out in the core of a
supergiant star there's a sequence of
fusion that goes from lighter elements
to heavier elements and it gets faster
and faster every step of the way
the countdown to death begins the inward
push from gravity takes over raising the
temperature in the core helium starts
fusing into carbon
there's enough helium to last about a
million years but it too runs out and
things start speeding up carbon gets
fused into neon and that takes about a
thousand years
neon fusing into silicon that takes
about one year
once it starts fusing silicon and iron
that takes one day it gets more and more
frantic it's it's kind of like a cooking
contest show where as the clock is
running down they're trying to do more
and more things and they get more and
more frantic until time's up
the star is now in its death throes
once iron production has started the
clock is ticking towards the cataclysmic
end of this star a giant ball of
incredibly dense iron forms in the
middle of the dying stars core this iron
sphere is several thousand miles across
and unbelievably hot it gets so hot
there the temperature almost becomes
meaningless I mean we're talking about a
billion degrees in the center of one of
these stars this extreme heat is caused
by fusion reactions more and more
reactions create heavier and heavier
elements and with each step less and
less energy is produced until iron is
created when you try to fuse iron nuclei
together that takes energy it doesn't
generate energy so once the core starts
to fuse iron its basically stealing its
own energy the growing iron core sucks
more and more energy from the star
gravity continues pulling in
overwhelming the outward pressure from
inside the star
everything gets crushed to unimaginable
degrees all of a sudden there's no
nuclear reaction to support the star
against the crush of gravity with
nothing left holding it up the star is
doomed gravity wins the edges of the
iron core collapse trillions of tons of
dense iron fall inward at a quarter of
the speed of light the star has now less
than one second left to live things
start to fall apart really quickly
the core collapse is so fast that the
outer layers of the star don't even have
time to react they're just hanging there
it's kind of like wily coyote when a
cliff collapses underneath them and he
doesn't even fall until he notices the
rest of the star collapses a trillion
trillion trillion tons of gas curdled
inwards
following the iron think about the
entire mass of a star that has been held
up by nuclear reactions inside all of a
sudden those nuclear reactions go away
in a split second
everything rushes into the middle
and that sets off the most dramatic
explosion in the universe
[Music]
the spectacular deathblow can outshine
all of the stars in the galaxy but
there's a problem we still don't fully
understand how a collapsing ball of iron
and tons of falling gas create a giant
fireball how this collapsing core
triggers a massive explosion is one of
the biggest mysteries in astrophysics